i did want to bring up uh i'm getting
sentimental uh
at this stage of things and i wanted to
bring up that
you started coming on our late night
show in the real
early days really really early and um
and then throughout the years in the
different iterations of the show
uh you've always been there for us
and i really you you've been a important
part
of you know what we wanted to do with
this show your
your comedy is so original and left
brain and
it was just it's always been very nice
for us to have you
come and be like a big part of what we
were trying to do thank well it meant a
lot
to me and i know that i can speak for
like all my
comedian kind of posse that your show
especially that it reminded me of the
way letterman's show was back in the day
of oh
our kind of comedy is getting some
representation this really
weird why not i want to try something i
mean the stuff that
the stuff that i could that artie
kendall the ghost crooner
that i one day i was working on a
tv show and for some reason the theme
song
for uh rockabilly polka dotted embryonic
fighter pilots got stuck in my head
yeah which is one of your things like
little things like that that you're like
i have this idea i don't really know
what to do with it let's put it out see
what happens with it
like that kind of that the fact that
that got
to have exposure really really was a big
deal for me
you know kept a lot of us going yeah
yeah
well it was uh you know it's so as you
can attest to and you too andy when you
when you get to do the thing you dreamed
of as a kid that's so
stupid and it's the thing that you get
yelled at
because people say stop doing that stop
screwing around
and get to and get to work and then you
grow up and someone says if you'll do
that
we'll give you a paycheck uh it's i
don't i don't think there's anything
more miraculous
in life it's just really nice the look
on your face when you would do
the random chuck norris stranger lever
but the look on your yeah but that
when you would do it like the third or
fourth time there was that look of like
i'm can you believe i'm like dude like
you were so happy
we used to pull this lever and it would
show clips of
these scenes from uh from texas ranger
chuck yeah uh walker texas ranger and we
would show these clips and they were the
most insane clips
and you can and so what happened was we
loved it it was my favorite thing and
then we were told that you have to stop
doing it and i said why
they said because all the actors want to
get uh you have to pay
all the actors and it's a fortune and if
you don't stop immediately
i mean literally it would have
bankrupted the show bankrupted all of us
you have to stop immediately and i was
crushed because i loved it and then i
told my producer no we're taking this to
trial
and he said what are you talking about
and i said i want to go to trial and i
want to show these
i want to show these clips and then i
want to turn to the jury and say
do you really think that's acting
i would have won i would have won
damn oh my god we gotta i know i know
uh it'll happen in my next life yeah
patton's podcast with his wife meredith
salinger
did you get my text premieres tomorrow
uh
wherever you get podcasts yes uh you
know thank you
so much for being such a big part of our
foolishness over the years pat and
oswald